this is known as an ASCII art animation
it is made of nothing but characters
that you can print to the screen colors
that you can display on it every block
that you see is exactly the size of a
character in this terminal window this
is a terminal you're looking at that
I've used to create an animation and I'm
here to talk about that
to talk about animating with ASCII or an
analysis of the code behind my pike on
2017 talked at the inaugural North Bay
Python I'm Brandon Rhodes by the way the
Wi-Fi password I figured out after he
said it is
I think Python 2017 I was sitting there
thinking what version of Python is too
is 207 one I I had no idea
so my pike on 2017 talk on the new
features that have been added to the
Python dictionary used ASCII animation
to just give you a small taste of that
as in a terminal screen and I would run
it and be able to show how when you
insert keys into a Python dictionary
they the first few are probably going to
fit just fine according to the last few
bits in their bit pattern but then if
you add one that tries to use the same
bit pattern it is going to collide with
the key that's already there and have to
be put in the backup location and I
thought I mean we call them collisions
shouldn't they look like collisions and
and so that was the the idea behind
using animation in my 2017 dictionary
talk I wanted things to visibly collide
so people then asked me how did you do
it how did you make these seamless
animations in ASCII and so I thought
that they deserved an answer and that's
the purpose of this talk and the answer
is
I did it badly and so I'd like to
explain that first a little bit about my
philosophies as a speaker some
guardrails that I tend to put around my
talks first I always have a per timer
slide that tells me based on how many
seconds are left till I need to finish
the presentation divided by the number
of slides that are left I always have a
timer that tells me well you know you
can only spend 15 seconds on this slide
before you're eating into the time of
the remaining slides because all I have
here is a terminal screen to help me
with this I have an assistant that will
be called in whenever I hit that time
limit and that will begin to destroy the
current slide so that I have to stop
speaking about it the so there it goes
so that's how I'm going to try to rein
myself in and not turn each slide into a
lecture a second thing I do in designing
talks is I try to do something with the
tools I'm using to constrain my design
space for example in most of my normal
presentations going back to 22 2002 my
very early talks at PyCon I write them
in restructured text about the only
tools I have available are to make a
paragraph to make a bullet list or to
make a block of code and I have to
somehow come up with a way to
communicate all my ideas just from
turning those elements into HTML and
applying some custom CSS so doing an
ASCII animation presentation kind of fit
the same mold it gave me a limited set
of tools a Python script a terminal
window in the Ubuntu mono font that
prevented me from sitting and playing
with the font all day or turning to
characters to get them just right by
taking that option away I don't spend
all my time fiddling with pixel-by-pixel
detail I guess I fiddled with character
by character detail instead which is a
lot faster there's a lot of fewer
characters than there are at pixels
third I try to go with very brief slide
this is a famously made famous by
Lawrence Lessig a decade or two ago the
idea is that short slides are less
distracting for the audience like right
now you're listening to me rather than
reading ahead to my next few bullet
points aren't you because you don't see
them until I advance short slides keep
you on track if each slide is
essentially just sentence you've got to
stay it'll be easy to stick with it
they also decrease the load on your
memory as a presenter easier for the
audience and easier for you the speaker
so I always try to go with very short
slides if I discover during practice of
my presentation that a slide has two
ideas inside that the slide is making me
say one thing and then remember and say
another I split it into two this
presentation has 129 slides for example
each of which are a simple idea that I
say and move on past no big lectures
that I have to give forth and finally
use a big font how big is this font it
is the biggest terminal font that still
fits the code on slide 86
literally so layout your talk and then
just increase the use small code samples
and increase the font size until the
largest slide barely fits the screen I'm
often just stunned by the fonts that
people think I can see from the back row
so those are my basic guardrails a per
slide timer so I keep moving constrain
the design space by using very limited
tools that I have to work with in brief
slides that each have one idea unless
it's a recap slide before and use the
biggest font I possibly can so all of
this worked very very well with this
idea of having the presentation in a
terminal window so I went to PI con 2017
and I gave the talk I wrote my own ASCII
animation library because frankly I
couldn't understand the others on pi PI
I did find a few asking
animation libraries and I looked at how
they worked and I'm like I can't
understand how to make my animation how
to write it in this framework
I'll save time by writing my own I did
get the talk done so there's two kinds
of challenges that I had to dig into in
order to get it done
technical and architectural I'm going to
tackle them in that order which is also
the order the ones I did pretty well and
the ones I did less well so it'll be a
good order for the story the technical
ones we can breathes through the
technical challenges were as follows I
wanted to have in the middle of this
animation I wanted to be listening for
keystrokes and have forward slide
backwards slide and repeat the current
slide if I wanted to show the animation
again all there at my fingertips is
actions that I could run but in this
loop that's running the animation and
praying stuff to the screen of course if
you say keystroke is just not standard
in read one character what happens the
animation stops and waits for you to hit
a key and the animation would freeze if
I ask for a character if I went in check
to see if a character had been typed
alright I knew my way around this I went
and consulted the documentation and I
used the Select call from the
identically name to select module in the
standard library to check whether there
were any characters waiting before
potentially blocking myself trying to
read them so that cop got past the
problem of sistent standard n dot read
wanting to freeze my animation I could
go read the character only if I was sure
I had typed one but my program then it
was now running the animation wasn't
frozen anymore but he couldn't see my
keystrokes until I pressed enter why was
it ignoring my keystrokes until I hit
Enter well this gets into a little bit
about how your Mac OS or Linux machine
thinks about the terminal you might
think that your process is connected up
to a raw device that lets you write
characters to the screen and lets
four characters from the keyboard but
it's a lie in between your process your
program and the terminal is something
called a termios driver the term iOS
driver is the source of many lies and
deceptions it's designed for the days
when terminals were very simple devices
teletype sitting in Bell Telephone
laboratories the kind of settings are
designed to help programs operate on
those old terminals the term is setting
that we're about to look at are not
controlled thank goodness
by writing special sequences you don't
write some bytes and have the term i/o
this driver wake up and think that those
are settings because what if you needed
to write those characters to the
terminal term IOT's gets out of the way
in that respect by having you use an
out-of-band not in the right call system
call to set its attributes you can go
learn about all of those attributes and
all of those settings by running man
termios or you can do it from the
command line run stty which is short for
set TTY settings - a for all and you
will see all of the settings that a
modern mac OS darwin or linux machine
has available all of which can edit the
data going out to the terminal or the
keystrokes coming back before you ever
get a chance to see them several of
these settings were fighting me as I
tried to write my animation library here
are a few here are the ones I had to
adjust first I have a driver between you
and the terminal well this brings up the
topic of the first setting that I want
to talk about in the middle of that big
man page is something called o4 meaning
a prefix meaning this is an output
setting newline carriage return this
sets up the rule that when you output a
newline the terminal actually gets sent
two characters carriage return is a
character it's a single bite character
that when you send it to the terminal
moves the cursor from wherever it is
back over to the left margin it is a
favorite of people writing ASCII
progress bars all you have to do is
carriage return right your progress bar
carriage return write it again and you
get what looks like a single line that
doesn't scroll everything off the screen
that changes each time you write it its
friend carriage returns friend is called
line feed yet
strictly speaking it just moves the
cursor straight down it stays in the
same column but moves from one row to
the next wing you can see this in fact
I'll bet many of you have seen this
before as follows now for simplicity
UNIX files only put a line feed at the
end of each line so when you run PS
sample program just to use it as example
here something interesting happens it
looks like each line ends with a
carriage return moving back to the left
margin and a line feed moving down but
it's a lie
PS is only pudding it's a UNIX program
it's only outputting line feeds at the
end of each line and then oh and then so
I guess the challenge is can I finish
before it's finished destroying the the
slide so PS is simply putting a bear
newline character at the end of each
line and the terminal driver is the one
adding in those carriage returns we can
see this as follows run s TTY - for off
Oh in LCR and then run PS again have any
of you ever been in a terminal window
where you ran a normal command like LS
and the output suddenly stair-stepped
strangely down the screen the reason is
that this is the truth
in truth PS only asks to move to the
next line and it relies on the default
terminal settings to get it back to the
- margin that's a so then that's a
that's probably the most famous setting
that people run into the most often but
some others are further down on the man
page there's an echo setting that is on
by default everything you type is echo
to type the letter R it'll just appear
on the screen whether the program you're
using wants it to or not enter my house
like all good tools includes a built-in
text editor right all tools need
built-in text editors that's turned on
by default so the that text editor is
called canonical mode controlled by the
eye cannon setting I will do a short
demo the normally if you type cat and
start typing a line of text cat has not
yet received any input at this point why
because the eye can an editor is reading
my keystrokes echo is on so I'm getting
them sent back to me and it's not until
you hit Enter that the term iOS line
editor concludes that you're done and
all at once sends those characters to
cat which then presents them back if is
TTY turn off canonical mode in run cat
again you will now see that and that you
know everything my backspace characters
everything else are going straight
through to cat because though the text
editor is off the the illusion is gone
and cat is having to deal with my raw
keystrokes as I type them the only
crazier thing I could do would be to
turn off echo cat enter
hello world
I hit backspace enter control C PS LS
PWD bash has never actually been echoing
those characters back to you it just
leaves the term iOS driver in the
default mode where it echos the
characters for it
so these settings the fact that the lion
editor is on by default and the
characters are echoed by default is
great for you know the programs like oh
and I'm going to show you a normal
program now I'm gonna run a special
command called reset reset is utter
magic it sets echo back to the default
it sets I it sets all of the settings of
not only the terminal but the term iOS
driver back to the default gets you back
to normal so I can show you that for
very simple programs like the desktop
calculator six-six add them in print
it's an RPN calculator built into Unix
it doesn't have to know about line
editing or back spaces or anything it
just leaves the terminal and its default
state and a line editor is automatically
sitting in front of it so it made small
programs very easy to write that needed
to work at the terminal reset command I
just showed you might for most of you
really be the most useful takeaway from
this entire from from this entire
keynote and so I will highlight what I
believe might be the most useful
sentence are pair of sentences in the
entire UNIX documentation not that they
ever tell you where to go find it so I
will quote from the man page to reset
this is useful after a program die is
leaving a terminal in an abnormal state
note you may have to type line feed
reset line feed the line feed character
is normally ctrl J to get the terminal
to work as carriage return may no longer
work in the abnormal state
you're probably used to being able to
hit enter to end the line that's because
of a terminal setting that can get
messed up control J is really the thing
that will get you to the next line so I
needed to turn those off and this is
great fun you get to like go into 80s or
retro mode because these settings are
each a bit - and 8r are powers of two
that define two bits that we need to
turn on or off in the big word of bits
that is the term IOT's settings so we
have to get the output flags by using a
standard library module called termios
and then we can get those flags and them
using the vertical bar with the echo bit
and you can see that that fourth bit
gets turned on to turn it off only time
you ever get to use the squiggle in
Python I've never found another use for
this the little squiggle the the tilde
operator gets a word and flips all of
the ones and zeros so we now have a zero
where we want to turn a bit off we use
and to get the bit turned off in the
settings so it works great it's fun and
it's like this 80s moment in the middle
of your programming day so those are the
settings and the things I had to be
careful of in the termios driver things
like echo things like canonical mode
what then did I have to learn about the
state of the terminal which is also a
stateful appliance which changes as you
use it to talk to the terminal and to
change its settings you have to use ansi
escape codes these are an indian
in band signal this is in the middle of
sending characters you throw in some
special character sequences that don't
get printed to the screen they instead
change the terminals state this fact
that these are in band signals that they
that they're in the same stream of
characters you're outputting lead to an
interesting hobby people used to have
they would share animations with their
friends
as plain text files because a text file
can have printable characters in it it
can also have these especial escape
codes let's go back to our little
standard 80 by 24 window apologize for
the small font but this animation
happens to be that size my father worked
at Bell Labs and back in the early 80s
right at this time of year what is this
a 2nd of December I think right at this
time of year people would start sending
back and forth to each other a little
file called train dot txt I see someone
who's very excited are you ready so
imagine you're at Bell Labs it's 1982
someone sends you this text file and you
say cat train dot txt wasn't that great
what went wrong
well that stream of text characters has
no timing information inside of it there
is not on most terminals a way to say
wait one second and then continue
processing so unfortunately on a modern
terminal we don't get to see the
animation unless we write a program that
prints out a file at 1,200 baud it's
it's it's a very it's it's just a little
loop that pauses between each byte here
is what it would have looked like on a
1200 baud terminal on someone's desk at
Bell Labs the flashes are where it's
ringing the terminal Bell to make a ding
ding sound is it
here it's gonna ding again ding ding now
I'm going to run less on this file to
let us see the truth behind it and less
is not it is it less is a smart program
it is not going to let the animations
start moving the cursor all over the
screen less is going to use I think
reverse video to show me where special
escape codes are and so you can see that
at the top is the email headers oh I'm
sorry this was 87 that this was last
sent from one person to another and you
can see here all of these escape codes
all of these special characters that
aren't D 96-95 printable ASCII
characters but are drawn from that first
32 remember always that man ASCII if you
spell it correctly will get up a table
that lets you remember how many 32 the
32 first character codes are all special
ones that means something to the
terminal and this is a text file that
because all of these instructions to the
terminal are in band are just bytes in
your data stream you can store them to
the file and watch them decades later if
I'm a one for one moment doubt the UNIX
system how many other animations from
1987 can you still play
the design they did has very very great
longevity so train dot txt these are in
band signals that you just write like
any other normal character but they do
things they move the cursor around and
things like that so I could have used a
big terminal library to introspect the
kind of terminal I had and write the
codes for me but I don't know I'm not
that kind of guy I just did it this way
I just said look there's like five
things I need to do is all I need to
know how to hide the cursor show the
cursor why because notice how annoying
it is we're gonna watch train again
watch because the train animation is
constantly sending the cursor all over
the place to draw the little train
engine and to make the lights on the
tree blink notice that there's all these
little ghostly cursors do you see
there's this little like little all
these little cursors like following the
train down the track that's because this
was not written by someone who knew to
turn those cursors off before displaying
it at least when I was preparing for my
Python app I can talk I thought the
cursor was really distracting having it
flicker everywhere so I used hide cursor
in a reset hide cursor to hide it show
cursor turns it back on when the program
exits the only other things I needed
were go to origin because I just go to
the upper left corner and just print as
many characters as there are characters
on the screen and it just fills up each
row with the slide I want to display and
then I need to set the foreground and
back how a background color when I want
part of the slide to be a different
color the eye I did all that inside of a
try finally so that if my program
crashed I mean I think it did once as I
was editing yet it would set I wouldn't
have to type reset if I set the echo and
I can and in show cursor back to normal
and always set your colors back it is no
fun to have it die when the color is
white on white
and then you can't see the trace back
the next technical thing that I had to
tackle was the fact that there the talk
was about the difference in dictionaries
between different versions of Python now
understand this animation program was
actually creating dictionaries live and
drawing them on the screen so from one
slide to the next I might need to change
versions of Python so that it would
change features and behavior so I used a
UNIX superpower called exact it is a
call that replaces a process the one
making the call with a new one without
leaving a dangling parent process
hanging around waiting here is my
favorite shelled Z shall I run PS okay
my current my shell is currently process
70 807 let us if I ran been - if I just
said bin - then 70 807 would now be the
CSH process a parent process waiting on
bash to complete but I know I'm not
going to use the SH again in this
session so let's exact bin - I'm now
inside of bash and it has become process
78 oh seven you're giving your slot in
the process table - another process
without leaving a parent dangling up
behind you this is very important if
during a slide deck you might restart
Python 128 times as I'm doing here
running so there's several versions of
it that are is a bit of a confusing
thing I found exact PPE was was one that
worked pretty well for me in the OS
module all I had to do was find what
version of Python I wanted to run for
the next slide I was advancing to and
then invoking the oh I hit repeat
instead of forward the here we are we've
moved forward
this meant that each of my slides could
run under a different version of Python
and it also meant I got rid of the need
for auto rebeaud I didn't need to have I
didn't need to stop and restart every
time I edited my slide deck program
because I was automatically be starting
every
time I move to another slide it was
really convenient it even wound up
helping me with dictionary stability one
problem is as I moved into the more
modern versions of Python the dictionary
has looked different every time I ran
because of the randomization they do and
and it's very hard to build narratives
around dictionaries when you don't know
when the keys will finally collide at
first this was very inconvenient I had
to because that's something that can
only be said at startup you can't adjust
it later I would just have to exit with
an error if I forgot to set that
environment variable when I ran my slide
deck every day when I'd sit down to work
on it I'd have to run it twice to
remember that well what's not realized I
could use exec I just put an if
statement at the top that says well if
the environment variable I needed to be
started with wasn't there when I started
let's just react myself exact same
program exact same arguments but throw
in the environment variable so that
Brandon doesn't have to remember to it
was really helpful so those were the
technical challenges and though several
of them snagged me for a few minutes as
I had to relearn how terminals worked I
got through them fairly well we will now
talk about my architectural issues how
can I store the screen now this is I
started off pretty well this part
survived how can I store the screen to
allow random access modification since
if I made just a big long string that
holds all of the rows of characters it's
difficult to edit so I decided to make
what I call the canvas I was drawing on
which is a list of characters starts out
as spaces one for every position on the
screen starting in the upper left and
you know going in the same order I'll
need to print them in down all the rows
to the bottom and then two corresponding
lists of foreground and background
colors if I want to write to this
because lists are mutable I can simply
use pythons on the bottom three lines
here really beautiful range assignment
operator - given that the of another
part of the program wants to scroll some
text on to this canvas at positions X
and
why all I need to do is I can just say
we'll set characters I 3j2 though
characters from that text and then go in
and set the foreground and background
colors as well when I was ready to print
it to the screen easy and this part
again survived and worked just fine you
this is essentially just for each
character yield the character and then
the caller will empty string dot join
this all together into a single bundle
of text that it can write so that the
frames appears quickly and a solid piece
as possible but I also whenever the
color changes between one character and
the next need to yield the special code
to the terminal that will change so that
if I've gone through some characters
that are black I then need to change and
send that signal so the next few will be
red or whatever but I only those who
remember those escape codes you saw a
minute ago are kind of big so I only
output them if they can't just reuse the
color of the previous character that all
worked great the problem came when I had
to tackle the question how do I write
animations using scroll I first thought
of it like this well animations unfold
through time an effect might last for a
second or two or three as I animate a
Python dictionary and those seconds are
made up of individual frames 30 I think
I think I wound up going with 60 per
second and and because that's a typical
refresh rate for a monitor like this so
smooth as possible 60 per second how can
I go ahead and plan out which effects
will be happening during which frames
well I like data structures and I
thought I'll just build a data structure
I will before hitting go I will study
the current slide and I will go through
and I will set up for each frame the
animations that it should call the
things that need to appear on the slide
for it to appear then I can just do a
loop starting at the first one call the
first list of functions on a canvas
second list of functions and for each of
those print
slide to the screen here's a sample
animation so we have an example to talk
about beautiful is better than ugly each
one fading in over exactly one second
I'll run it again down down so that's a
sample animation that I can now use to
kind of show you how this worked as I
wrote a routine called fade in you give
it the script that it's going to add
itself to a start time a duration and
the x and y location and the text that
you want it to display all it's got to
do is go add some kind of function or
callable to the correct frames in that
list of slides to get itself scheduled
so that as the animation proceeds those
will appear this was my first try at
getting animation working so we need to
write fade in it needs to build some
kind of cobble that it can stick into
all of these pre scheduled frames
well where am I going to get one of
those from Python has essentially two
best clap best of class ways of doing
this one is a bound method you create a
class and you give it's a knit method
all the information about the animation
it will be doing and it then has to
store away all of the relevant
information that will be needed during
the animation itself self dot duration
equals duration and so forth and then it
can get its method called self dot draw
and go add it to the correct frames in
the script what is self dot draw it is
the actual caller of scroll that is
going to be writing self dot string to
the canvas itself dot X&Y having
consulted you know the current time T
that's also passed in to figure out
whether we're now at the point where we
should be all the way black or still
partially gray and that would work
however there's an option I always enjoy
better
which is a closure self goes away all of
those assignment statements go away and
you use the magic this was added to
Python in the 2000s you use the magic of
the fact that if you save away an inner
function like the draw here that's
inside a fade in it for free will
remember what duration XY and string
were back when it was defined so here
I'm appending a plane draw function that
inner function to the script where I
want it to be called and later without
needing self and an instance attribute
references it'll be able to get to the
information it needs there are two
disadvantages that I will go ahead and
say despite my assistant to having a
class one on a class instance if you
want to go back later and look at what
duration and X&Y were from outside you
can do it with a closure there's no easy
way to having been returned that draw
function to go ask it what it thinks x
and y are you also can't modify it x y
and string are just fixed here they can
never be edited later now in this
application I was never planning on
going back and introspecting this fade
animation or trying to change its X&Y
but in applications where you need to a
class instance is really the best thing
closures are great when you just want an
inner function with a memory that isn't
going to forget things but that you
don't need to go into respect or modify
later so that worked pretty well I got a
first few words to fade in and appear on
the screen they looked kind of like
professional slides this was going
pretty well then I ran into a problem as
soon as I reached the next level of
complexity what if the text isn't fixed
like the word beautiful what if it is
generated by another column like
something that knows how to draw a big
Python dictionary so if the slide if the
material I want to fade in is produced
by another draw another animation
routine one kind of stock my draw
routine is called with T in canvas and I
know that I'm going to have to call that
other animation with tea and canvas but
that other animation it's just gonna go
draw to the canvas without asking me I
won't know which information on the
canvas was drawn by it and should be
affected by my fade and what information
might already have been there from other
components drawing to the page I thought
for a moment what if I just monkey patch
scroll and then I fought I thought no
monkey patching is software bankruptcy
monkey patching means that things have
gotten as bad as they can possibly get
so I wasn't ready to give up so I
thought through what is my problem my
problem is that animations aren't
composable these little things I'm
writing that draw can't be stacked or
layered I looked at the code again and
made a crucial observation canvas that
I'm passing to every single animation is
never actually touched by enough by an
intermediate effect like fade in and so
I thought what if I switch up passing a
noun the canvas and instead pass the
verb because a bottom level draw routine
it never goes in and indexes the canvas
directly it always goes through scroll
because that's more convenient so why
does it need to know about the canvas
object why am I even passing that what
if I pivoted to making these animation
routines simpler where they know a bit
less about the way the framework is
structured what if I just give them the
scroll routine that they are supposed to
use and don't let them touch the canvas
yet that was the big win that let me
finish this out and get a talk ready for
PyCon 2017 back in May because this
change one little change from a noun to
a verb gave
we composability when I am called it's
time to draw a slide 50 and so draw is
called with 50 comma and a a presumably
the scroll routine that will really
write to the canvas I call the next
animation down with a different scroll
routine that applies a fade to each
piece of text that's displayed all of a
sudden I'm in control of what that
subordinate routine does and can make
its output be a a I can adjust its
output in any way that I want having a
function inside of a function inside of
a function seemed a little bit much
but it was time to finish the slides up
and attend the conference so that's the
formal library was in when I presented
at PyCon 2017
which is why I haven't shown it to
anyone so many wrapper functions
functions inside of functions
so after PyCon and in preparation for
this talk I wanted to think about that
disaster and what had led to it so let's
review fade in this animation layered on
top of another one needs to have an
inner function that itself needs to have
an inner function and the draw
dictionary and you know it has a
subordinate one draw item that draws one
item of the dictionary they also if they
are going to be intercepting and using a
lower-level drawing tool also have to
have their own version of scrawl so
let's to see why trace where the data
goes do you ever do this with your
program sit down and draw a picture and
trace where the information goes the
order here is that first we call fade in
and it gets its dot draw and goes and
puts it into the script then as we run
through the animation every frame is
gonna call draw with a different value T
it is going to call draw a dict it is
going to call draw item which thinks
it's calling the real scroll function
scroll function but is really calling
the inner scroll function of draw
dictionary that calls what it thinks is
the real draw scroll real scroll
function that brights on the real canvas
but it's not it's the one from fade in
that then really gets to draw on the
canvas now let's look at the data so
this worked let me say this worked but I
wasn't happy so let's look at that
picture and think about the data that's
passing as draw calls dictionary draw
calls dictionary calls draw dictionary
calls draw item like nothing much is
changing all what we're doing is passing
the current time all the way down
without even modifying it the current
frame number the interesting thing
happens on the way back we start with an
XY a string in some colors and that
changes at each level as it's passed up
it's almost like hiding inside of this
horrible set of inner functions is a
system for producing tuples and then
applying simple filters to the values in
the tuples can and this is how this
presentation is written can we write an
ASCII art library that's kind of a good
parts version of the one that I just
described here is a no scrawl solution
I've restructured to explicitly defer
drawing to later
now that previous one when the innermost
you know and one called what it thought
was the scroll function I was implicitly
secretly deferring it I wasn't letting
it draw to the canvas I was going to go
through some other steps first but let's
make that explicit let's make it
explicit that we're going to wait and
not draw these things until the end so
I'm going to define a frame that we're
gonna you know one of these frames of
the animation it is no longer a canvas
it is simply going from the point of
view of the drawing routines it's going
to be a list of tuples that each
describe a piece of text to be drawn
using the parameters were from
with an animation is simply going to be
a generator that builds and returns
these lists
this is composable and i will show you
how with four simple calls I can run
that beautiful is better than ugly
animation each of them feeding in over
one second here we go to Center a piece
of text I don't have to go right on a
canvas now all I have to do is yield a
list of tuples and somewhere out there
the my caller the ASCII animation
framework will go due to the drawing for
me so I just given the length of the
text I figure out where to Center it and
all I have to do I'm a little infinite
animation that's going to sit there and
make the text display until I move the
frame the slide forward to the next one
all I have to do is yield up for each
frame that little tuple over and over
and over again simple easy to write no
inner functions no callbacks
okay fade in is more complicated because
it needs to edit what another animation
produces so it does this it produces
given its duration the list of levels
zero through one that it's going to
apply to the two fading the background
color to the foreground one it then for
each frame it's given for each list of
tuples it's gonna turn around and return
or yield I should say its own list of
tuples where each of the incoming tuples
is edited to give it a different
foreground color done if we want several
animations running simultaneously we can
use zip which remember will just sit
there and run a bunch of generators
simultaneously returning to us all of
their outputs that correspond to each
other what everyone thinks should be on
the first frame the second frame the
third frame if I want to combine them
all I have to do is loop over all of
those lists making a single list of
tuples to send back up to the animation
engine
and this is how the animation looks line
1 line 2 in line 3 are very simple
primitive centering zuv three pieces of
text at different Y values I first okay
animation is running now I first yield
from fade in which is going to fade in
is going to return one seconds worth of
line one fading from nothing into
visibility on the screen I then yield
another seconds worth of animation where
lying one is now fully visible and line
two is fading in finally for one second
I fade in line three and end by having
all three lines fully visible and here
it is running switching things around
and foregrounding the data and for
grounding the fact that each of these
animators is returning something that
other animators have the right to edit
and change in filter before it gets
handed back for drawing on the canvas
was the key to making this a framework I
was happy with that I might even
open-source tomorrow or something so
well the challenges I faced technical
challenges I would give myself an A I
did an okay job back in May
setting the term IOT's values to get it
where my animation could run but that
design was at best a c-minus I mean I've
I mean functions inside of functions
inside of functions but the problem is
you see that there's this ugliness there
but you have a talk do so sometimes you
have to get something like right I got
it to the point where it was barely
composable we saw you know that
sometimes you just have to get something
to the point where it at least is
sufficient and just run with it but part
of the reason for my giving talking
about this in a keynote is it finally
let me go back and do this right my-y a
c- because and this is very important to
be thinking about my code wound up more
complicated
then the problem it was trying to solve
this seems to happen to us so often but
it can be so difficult and take months
sometimes to see the transform that will
get us out of that situation and let us
reduce the complexity of the code down
to something more roughly approximating
you know I'm trying to put characters on
the screen need it to be this hard in
conclusion you can give the talk the
clean architecture at PyCon Ireland
three years ago in 2014 and still
struggle to produce code that is shaped
enough like its data I'm Brandon Rhodes
thank you very much
[Applause]